[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
mercy is wasted on those who defile
birth world
[Music]
[Applause]
clean savagery is no match for skill
yet again the new gang
you chosen destiny
[Applause]
are you
destroy our enemies before they destroy
us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome the producer of the MKX
pro league and compact class your host
mr. Joshua gray Los Angeles and hello to
everyone watching around the world
welcome to Mortal Kombat 11 the reveal
I'm Joshua green I'll be your host for
today's monumental event are you all as
excited as I am to be here today I hope
so because we have some truly awesome
stuff to share with you and I am so
pumped to reveal some of the surprises
Mortal Kombat 11 has in store and I've
got some excellent guests here to help
me out Ed Boon and the NetherRealm
Studios team are here to talk about the
new storyline and the tons and tons of
content they've been working on for you
Tyler Lansdowne is in the building along
with some of your favorite Mortal Kombat
pros plus we have some secret special
guests in attendance that I can't wait
to bring up here including some
real-life badasses behind our characters
in just a few minutes you will be the
first people on the planet to fully
experience the bone-crushing brutality
of Mortal Kombat 11 prepare to get hype
we are about to reveal even more
gameplay for the first time in a
worldwide premiere this is the most
blood splashing gore spewing spine
snapping action you have ever seen in a
Mortal Kombat game ladies and gentlemen
please welcome to the stage creative
director of NetherRealm Studios and the
co-creator of Mortal Kombat
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Edie
you and your team at nether own Studios
have done it again there is so much to
unpack here and I'm sure you can't wait
to dive into some of the gameplay yeah
you know you
we've been biting our tongues since you
know six months ago around III dine to
dine to show you guys this game but we
really wanted to kind of build the
suspense this is absolutely gonna pay
off for that all right and I'll let you
do the honors take it away yeah you guys
first I think the first thing you wanted
to do is see the actual game so just
let's let's just roll them here
[Applause]
so we're very excited to show you first
look at Mortal Kombat 11 nobody else has
seen this today we have seven characters
to show you some returning some new
there's far more in this game we'll be
able to show you right here but we do
want to hit on the enhancements from the
game of fighting and the custom
character variations
[Applause]
Garrus is a new fighter in the game and
who can she has a really cool time
control abilities you know mortal and
NetherRealm games we really try to add
something new Mortal Kombat X we
introduced a feature call the character
variations three versions of every
single character MK 11 is expanding on
that idea
creating custom character variations the
player can actually create the eye
themselves so you notice they're
selecting different versions of
scorpions some operated by the player
some are created already in the game
same thing with maracas
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the cotton Warriors are legendary
why don't you free are thrown back the
should I buy you embrace nature sort so
this is a Mortal Kombat games to expect
the fighting to be brutal MK 11 sees the
return of Baraka is a fan favorite from
Mortal Kombat 2 so let's see some of the
moves he does here Nazi outdone scorpion
has a few tricks up his sleeve
okay now without getting too technical
getting into some of the geeky fighting
game Bach what moments not their mortal
comp traditionally we've had one meter
that's a shared resource amongst the
offense defense and the super moves
mortal kombat axes inch separating all
three of those so we have a horizontal
meter as the offense attacks vertical
meters the defensive attacks
SEPA rockets gonna shooting too using
his offensive moves also can extend this
leg staff here into a throw with a also
scorpion here is going to escape up from
the knockdown using his defensive meter
and you're going to notice here that the
fatal blow is that's actually tied to
30% of the of the health meter when is
reduced you get fatal blow available
this adds completely new dynamic and
tension to the fighting both a maraca
and scorpion have a fatal blow right now
Baraka wins this fight
so scorpion missed this fatal blow
attack but it actually will regenerate
after a cool-down period so you notices
his fatal flaw is established he can
pull it off
[Music]
and now to be outdone Baraka now has his
fatal blow available
and of course it wouldn't be mortal
combat without fatalities
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we're gonna quickly talk here about we
have custom variations on this player
various a screen that players can create
modify and collect multiple versions of
every character there are a ton of
features that you can customize from the
costume pieces the intros the victories
as well as a huge variety of skins here
every constant every fighter has three
costume pieces you see scorpion they're
changing the mask here picking a new one
you can actually program these at
different attributes see we're swapping
out the spirit or the katana for a new
one and of course scorpions iconic spear
can be swapped out for one as well now
this visual here is going to give you an
idea of kind of like the dramatic
differences you can have in the
different variations of scorpion hair
this is the case with all the fighters
so you're going to know a scorpion barak
all the kind of variations you're going
to see you know playing people online
and why not
our second fight here is Sonia versus
versus Scarlett who was a returning
character from Mortal Kombat 9 trust me
I'm not your type
both Sonia and Scarlett would turn with
their classic moves as well as some new
ones Sonia has a bunch of gadgets that
she can play with here while Scarlett
has her signature blood attacks
we're gonna take a look at some of the
nuances we have we have a new feature
called a flawless block a perfectly
timed block will open a window for
countering attacks watch Scarlett doing
a quick hop you can evade lo attacks and
also open another window for countering
boom now noticed
Sonia's health is reached below 30% when
it reaches there again you're going to
notice the fatal blow is available
that's when you can really devastate
again Sonia has her fatal blow ready so
she can take release it
[Applause]
so that was enough damage to release
fatal blow available for Scarlet Witch
she'll attack here
which is enough to win the match and you
might seen a glimpse of this fatality
here
[Music]
so that's a little piece of MORTAL
KOMBAT 11 but i i'm guessing maybe you
guys want to see some fatalities a
little more more okay we're gonna roll
this footage i can't wait for you to
check that out this
[Music]
[Applause]
okay first of all Scarlett has returned
what has it been like to bring back this
fan favorite that we haven't seen since
Mortal Kombat 9 yeah we we introduced
Scarlett as a DLC character in Mortal
Kombat 9 and she's been one of the most
demanded returning characters so we knew
we had to kind of abide by that I know
everybody's scarred out there super
stoked as well all right we saw some
classic combatants like scorpion
sub-zero plus we have dark Raiden and
Baraka is back
we saw Baraka rip somebody's face off so
okay we also have some new fighters for
you and your team what is this process
like not only to create new characters
but to refresh some of the classics
refreshing and deciding which ones to
come back is pretty much you guys you
know we really hear we hear what you
guys say as far as creating characters
that's that's some of the most fun we've
had you know Kerris is a new character
that we have a really cool look at
you're gonna see a little bit later but
that process is usually very
collaborative with you know the people
looking forward to that folk so we
witness combos fatalities but one of the
hallmarks that Mortal Kombat has always
been the rich detailed stories so what
can we look forward to in Mortal Kombat
xi when it comes to the story yeah you
saw a glimpse of the beginning of the
story here we actually have a video here
it's the entire opening cinematic the
whole prologue of the story it really
picks up right after MK 9 and I think
you guys are gonna get a big kick out of
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Simon
[Music]
but you wear my amulets finally you
embrace the truth feet elder gods deny
the truth I was cast out for speaking
the truth
I embrace shinnok is that mercy is
wasted on those who defile her throne I
will destroy our enemies before they
destroy us starting with you not even
you can kill an elder God
there are fates worse than death
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Iren delivery - okay and your
NetherRealm engines you'll serve as
warning and an emblem of my
[Music]
[Music]
this is not to a destination aku once
again the Thunder God has upset the
balance of history no this
the arc of universe bends to my will
[Music]
it is only a matter of time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
edie that was amazing April 23rd cannot
come soon enough
so the story picks off right after MKX
dark rain rains time is being
manipulated how fun was it to dive into
the rich mortal kombat lore and design
moments when these legendary characters
confront a different version of
themselves yeah that was the most fun
about you know how we created this story
we basically introduce a character
chronica who has been kind of running
the show since the first mortal kombat
everything that was happening was it to
her plan up to the point where Raiden
kind of screw things up and that's when
she's kind of stepping in and she's just
going to play tricks with time that's
gonna introduce situations where old
characters meeting their younger selves
and it's it's it's such a great great
story mode we could not be more proud of
this Ed Boon thank you so much for being
here give it up for the legend ladies
and gentlemen now I have one more
question before we go what other changes
have you made for this installment we
have something really special for Mortal
Kombat 11 we have a real-life badass
playing one of our most iconic Claire
Katz characters in the game and we
cannot wait for two to make this
announcement let's take a look
you've been looking for me starlet
right so new blade calling an air
support
sony blade was the first like kick-ass
girl and i saw come onto the scene and
I've always admired her and admittedly
kind of emulated her and you know in my
own way and now I get to try and be here
the first time I can remember playing
Mortal Kombat my mom was a college
professor and one of her students
actually let me play and I was
completely like button masher but I was
break it in and I beat him as Raiden it
was like the first time did I beat the
dolphin like anything yeah I thought it
was like the absolute coolest
boy see a character has been really
different and really interesting and fun
because I don't have to think about how
I look and only about how I sound it
almost gives me permission to be as
ridiculous as humanly possible because
no one's looking at no one's judging and
all that matters is what it sounds like
I could have been a Mortal Kombat for
almost as long as I can remember or a
little kid I love me some more
[Music]
what drew me to Mortal Kombat honestly
it was the first game that had like real
intrigue of just more than okay I'm
gonna hit this guy hit me in two wins it
wasn't just like who's the better
fighter it was why is this person mad at
that person and this and that it just
drew me in to think about more than just
fighting but the world that they live in
and yeah it's been a great experience
being Sonya buddy
[Applause]
please give a warm welcome to the
reigning raw woman's champion the first
woman ever to be inducted into the UFC
Hall of Fame and the voice of Sonya
Blade Ronda thank you so much for being
here how does it feel to be part of an
iconic franchise like Mortal Kombat and
to be voicing Sonya Blade this is a
dream come true I really I tried to grow
up to be Sonya Blade as close as I could
like I feel like if Raiden came down
right now and had to pick three warriors
Mortal Kombat like I would definitely be
that person and now instead of being the
closest thing I can be to Sonya Blade I
am actually Sonya Blade Earthrealm is in
good hands so how did you prepare for
this role is there anything that you did
specifically to get into Sonja's
headspace or things that you pulled from
your fighting experience well it was
very secretive this project I really
didn't get to know very much at all and
so I I tried to inhabit her headspace by
by actually emulating her her fighting
style and I got to do her Khurana
on Triple H at WrestleMania so he was
Makino for the evening and I've been
watching the the gameplay and Sonya
actually does a rolling juju Khatami
armbar that is like my absolute favorite
she does rip somebody's arm off with it
I can totally do that and so yeah I was
just getting my in your Sonya what
excites you most about Mortal Kombat 11
I'm excited about a lot you know I mean
they really do outdo themselves every
single time and when you don't think
that it could do it anymore I mean it's
it's blowing my mind I mean I didn't
think the graph has to get any better
and they obviously are I mean I have no
idea what's going to happen like with
the rest of story I know my parts but
even still I'm just like there's so much
secret involve that I just cannot wait
to see how the story unfolds I there's
just there's so much that I'll be
probably ignoring my family for a while
and showed up in a room
don't worry we're all taking off work
now I already know the answer to this
question but which character you most
excited about from Mortal Kombat 11
Sonya Blade of course I kind of hope I
see Johnny
Ronda thank you so much for being here
ladies and gentlemen give it up one more
time for the voice of Sonya play the
Mortal Kombat 11 Ronda Rousey more
dreams coming true next up I want to
invite someone you all know and love up
here to talk about some of the things we
have coming up for you on Kombat cast
this year please give a warm welcome to
Tyler Landsdowne great to have you man
so tell us what's going on with that
cast is here so excited to be here for
the reel of reveal of MK 11 there's so
much cool stuff coming up this year and
I will let you know right now that our
first combat cast is in less than two
weeks January the 30th that's right
around the corner what do you have plans
well the first one's gonna be pretty big
new logo we got a few surprises in store
for you I'm not gonna talk about it
right now but whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
bro who is that who I think it was yeah
now we're gonna wait until the 30th to
find out
you're gonna want to re-watch that and
see that is where our first comeback has
to be live on every single Mortal Kombat
social channel I don't want any of you
to miss this okay we got so much good
stuff coming up but I need to ask for a
friend okay is there gonna be a
collector's edition actually yes there
is a collector's edition this year and
it's badass
and I want everyone to see right now
what we've put together okay that mask
looks incredible what is it you have one
[Applause]
I just walked back there this is one of
the coolest collector's edition we've
ever done in addition to this mask if
you preorder any version of the game you
get Shao Kahn and access to the beta
which begins on March 28th man I I don't
want this I need this put me down for
one I am sold and you can purchase yours
two at your local gamestop here in the
United States for everyone else around
the world get more information at Mortal
Kombat com that just about wraps it up
for us here on stage but stay tuned
because we have a lot more coming up
with a live stream of Tyler you're gonna
be interviewing some folks and a live
look at the reveal floor here in Los
Angeles and a pro exhibition featuring
some of your favorite Mortal Kombat
combatants we do have one more big
reveal but first a big THANK YOU to Ed
Boon and the NetherRealm Studios TV for
joining us
and of course Sonya Blade herself Ronda
Rousey
being here today she's great and I want
to extend a huge thanks to everyone
tuning in from all over the world thank
you so much for being a part of the
Mortal Kombat 11 reveal we hope you're
excited for the official release of
Mortal Kombat 11 on April 23rd o so Josh
mentioned the reveal just a second ago
are you ready to see it here we go
[Music]
[Music]
Thunder come lightning do you fear
nothing garrus nothing within your power
rate
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Fatone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]